joining me now here on the rich eisen
show is a man who is going to be putting
the gloves on this weekend at the mgm
grand for a huge fight the number one
consensus pound-for-pound fighter
superstar and united unified wba wbc and
wbo super middleweight world champion
taking on
kayla plant canelo alvarez here on the
rich eisen show how are you canelo
very good thank you good i am doing
better for talking to you thank you so
much uh for for joining here what does
this fight mean for you this weekend
means a lot for my legacy is very
important maybe is the most important
fight of my career
because the magnitude of the of the
fight is
is really important for me so
to accomplish this
is is is huge or for my country for my
team for me
is really important
so what what do you think your your
legacy is that you think that uh it's
potentially either on the line or can be
burnished with a with a win this weekend
no it is
very important for my legacy because
very few fighters accomplish
this so
for me being the spirit fighter in the
spirit champion is
is really is really important because
just five fighters in the boxing in the
history of boxing accomplished so that's
why it's very important for me so you
know obviously um the the big fight that
just happened at the heavyweight um
level
what do you say you're considered by
many as the face of boxing right now
that your face is associated with the
sport in a way that
nobody else who's lacing them up is
right now what would you say to people
that that boxing isn't
as big as it needs to be or used to be
what would you say to something like
that
canelo alvarez no uh i just
just look at my numbers look look at my
numbers and then
right
boxing is huge boxing is big and
uh
for the fans of boxing
always
always is is good but uh they talk they
say but uh look at the numbers and and
then we can see
and um so this weekend uh as you as you
get set to uh as you say continue your
your legacy
do you feel that potentially you've
faced floyd mayweather too early in your
career yeah that's what i that's what i
thinking about it but uh
i did what i did and and it is what it
is
but uh
i think
i don't have experience right there
uh
so young
a lot of things but it is what it is i
learned from i learned from that fight
and
and
and i don't take that fight like a like
a loss
how do you take it
like a lesson
lesson in my life
by boxing because
for me is i learned a lot from there
the freeze
big
stage
so
a really good fighter there with a lot
of skills and mentally for me i learned
a lot so
this life
for me for my life
was very important who wins now uh floyd
on that day or canelo alvarez from this
coming saturday night who wins
we're never gonna know that
i feel like can we that's like easy
well i i obviously you're a different
human being now too uh canelo i i've got
to tell you um on the all-access show
you
telling your your young son that it's
okay to cry
is one of the neatest things i've ever
seen i've got two boys
myself at 13 and 10.
what what lesson do you think you were
telling your son that that was beautiful
i don't know
that's does that day i just i just hear
him say hey i fall
and i don't cry
and
it's okay it's okay try it you need to
cry cry if something hurts and something
happening you you feel you need to cry
christ
is
it's okay
right that's that's does i just want to
explain him
it's okay christ
nothing wrong
right there
yeah and he he picked up that lesson uh
yeah that it's okay to cry
yeah i know he got it
when was the last time you cried canelo
alvarez i don't remember yeah yeah
i cry at commercials
i cried tv commercials that's the way
i've gotten right now in my life
um in the few minutes that i have i have
left with you here um
again returning to the sport of boxing
as a as a whole what do you think of the
paul brothers
joining boxing what do you think of of
them and what they're bringing
to the city
it's okay he brings
they bring
more more fans to to boxing so it's okay
for me i don't have anything with that
okay and um you know lots has been made
of a guy like say for instance nate diaz
potentially leaving ufc to go to boxing
i've seen pictures of the two of you
together is that a
a fight that ever down the line that's
something you'd you'd want to
consider
nate diaz or anything no i don't know
from ufc how about taking a ufc and
taking somebody that comes out and wants
to get a piece of you in that regard
would you ever want to do something like
that you you never say no but uh that is
now in my in my mind right now right not
make sense for me okay what about just
your future after this fight what is
your plan after a fight like this but we
don't know we don't know i uh we hundred
percent focus on this fight
in this fight and then we'll see
okay well canelo alvarez i appreciate
the time have a good uh have a good
weekend
thank you go enjoy the fight and best
you can and
you already could see you've already you
already got a
split lip right there right is it what
do you got there on your is that
something you already got going on no
when you lose weight um
you know
happens have a good fight sir thanks for
coming on the show greatly appreciate it
thank you that's canelo alvarez one of
the all-time greats right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here